So I'm going to
write out a number
that we're going to think about
how we could say or actually
write that number.
So I'm just going
to write it out.
I'm going to resist the
temptation to actually speak it
out because that's
normally how I operate.
But I'm not going to
do that right now.
So there's several ways
that we can pronounce.
So I encourage you to pause
it and try to pronounce it,
yourself.
You might not even
need to pause it.
Well, the first
thing that jumps out,
well we've got
20,000 and then some.
So maybe we should
write it that way.
So we've got 20,000.
20-- actually let
me write it out
as numbers first to
really decompose it.
So we have 20,000.
And then what do we
have on top of that?
Well we have 5/10.
This is the tenths place.
So we can literally
write that as 5/10.
5/10.
Then we have 0, 0/100.
I'll write that as a
hundredths place just so
that we can keep track of it.
And then finally,
we have 7/1000,
that's the 1000th place.
So we could write
that, plus 7/1000.
So if we would write
down everything
that I just spoke
out loud, we would
say that this is 20-- let me
write that a little bit neater.
This is 20,000.
20,000 and 5/10.
And 5-- let me write out the
word-- and 5/10 and 7/1000.
Now, this isn't the
only way to say this.
Another way of
thinking about it is
to try to merge the 5/10 and the
7/1000 in terms of thousandths.
So let's think about this.
So we could write this
as-- so once again, we
would have our 20,000.
But instead of 5/10
and 7/1000, let's
write our 5/10 in
terms of thousandths.
And the easiest way to do it
is to multiply the numerator
and denominator,
both here, by 100.
So then we will
have-- so this 5/10
is the same thing
as 500 over 1,000.
And the 7/1000 is still 7/1000.
And these two
combined are 507/1000.
So we could just call
this 20,000 and 507/1000.
so let's write that down.
So we could just say this
is 20,000 and 507/1000.
This is 1/1000, while this right
over here, 1,000, of course,
actually represents 1,000.
So we got 20 thousands,
that's that right over there,
and 507/1000.